all right Sprint's are Allyson Felix
just made history if you heard this
breaking the record for winning the most
World Championship gold medals
Felix spent pass Usain Bolt's gold medal
record at the world Track and Field
Championships in Doha Qatar just ten
months after an emergency c-section she
earned her record-breaking 12 and 13
gold medal as a member of a 4 4 by 400
relay team and all she now has 27
Olympic world medals must be heavy on
your neck to watch her mom Allyson Felix
is here for an interview that you'll see
only on CBS this morning welcome Alison
so let's go to that day that you broke
all the records so you get up do you eat
breakfast what do you eat or are you
listening to music are you lacing up
your shoes saying I'm gonna break a
record today so take us through the race
before you go yeah I woke up I had some
oatmeal some fruit just relaxed a little
bit I did listen to a little music a
little Beyonce got the alter ego going
but no I didn't have any you know
thoughts of breaking a record you know
that wasn't on my mind for me this year
was really about overcoming and that's
what was on my mind so when you broke
the record you thought what I was just
like wow you know I I didn't expect it
you know and it was just amazing the
amount of support that I got and also
was just reassuring that you know I'm on
my path back in addition to beating
international competition on the track
you also beat the odds and surviving a
13-hour flight with an infant on the way
over there by the mom life it feels like
winning a gold what was it like to have
your daughter be witnessed I think for
the first time now to these victories I
was amazing you know I want to be a good
role model to her and you know this year
was all about fighting you know fighting
for so much and I want to eventually you
know tell her that story of that but
she'll be able to see you know that I
did try to overcome some adversity your
daughter spent 29 days in the NICU
yeah which I mean I had a week with my
daughter in the NICU it's those are
really nervous days they are it's such a
heavy place you know there's so much
going on and so much doubt and
uncertainty and struggling three pounds
right yes how early was she she was two
months early early as though
really scary situation and we really
weren't sure you know which way things
were gonna go so how did you know even
that 10 months after an emergency
c-section
that you were even ready to get back on
the truck seems your body would still be
out of whack it still is getting there
you know ways to go but you know just
really talking to my doctors about you
know this new body that I have and when
I was cleared to get back out there and
I started slowly it was a gradual
process I started walking and eventually
Wayne made my way did it feel really
different it did you know I was it's
very humbling you know things that once
came really easy to me we're now very
difficult it's distressing to point out
that most of the other countries that
you're competing against on the track
there those those runners come from
countries where parents get protections
in pregnancy and also in maternity leave
you've taken a fight public to make sure
a fleet get protections under these
contracts what does the country need to
do and what more needs to be done at a
corporate level to see changes happen a
lot I mean this is an issue that
everyone is affected by and I tackled it
in my industry but I think that's just
really the starting point you know I
that's why I want to leave behind it's
changes for the next generation and for
my daughter
I loved your argument in the in the in
the essay she says you know being
pregnant is not a performance reduction
these contracts were saying oh well
you're not running you're not running as
fast well you know you change the
language I think change the language and
you're still you know you're using my
likeness and I'm making an appearances
you're still working extremely hard
you're still training after Nike after
you had this dispute with Nike they
changed the language in the contracts
were you satisfied with what they did um
I was I mean I think you can always do
more but I was grateful I was
disappointed that I had to fight so hard
in that in 2019 that this is still an
issue I've since moved on to a great
partner Athleta and I'm really happy I
feel like our mission really in lines of
empowering women and girls but yes I was
I felt like they did the right thing
what is the issue that we really need to
understand exactly that we don't get
what is it I think it's that you know
once you have a baby your career is not
over you know that you can have a
flourishing career on the track or
wherever it is
and that there's still more left to give
and that you shouldn't be penalized for
that so we gonna see you and your
daughter at the Olympics in 2020 that's
the plan
working hard to be there it'd be your
fifth Olympics but they never get old
sweet let's talk about your daughter
because your priorities really change I
love your Instagram on the 18th you said
entering my 13 November during my 33rd
years stronger and empowered learning to
allow myself to be vulnerable
then by Thanksgiving it's like houston
we have a problem with the baby and your
priorities totally change on that day
yeah Mike we're going to a photo shoot I
was and I was still trying to go in the
dye for the doctor told me to go to the
hospital but my daughter really helped
me to find my voice you know to speak
out on these issues that I normally
wouldn't have and I'm really to try to
create some change so she's been my
motivation and without sounding stupid
with two O's how are you able to run
when you're I'm not a runner obviously
yeah how are you able to do that um you
just do it you know you're you feel much
heavier thing I use them a fit split you
know to help secure my belly and you
know your body can do amazing things and
you know you make sure you talk to your
doctor and that you're all cleared but I
continue to train and I felt great and I
think it really made me stronger we're
rooting for you in 2020 and your fight
for women's rights and for parental
rights here thanks so much for being
thank you for being here